hey guys Pete here it's gonna be my
things you might have missed video for
Twin Peaks season 3 part 16 no knock no
doorbell I didn't exactly number them
the same way because a couple of them
are connected so I'm just gonna run
through the list that I put together
there's quite a few interesting things
that pops up here and just a quick
spoiler warning if you haven't watched
this episode yet if you're not caught up
with Twin Peaks season 3 through part 16
you're gonna want to stop watching so
the first thing that came to mind when I
was reading was is that we've never seen
the original die-in now this can this
caused a little bit of confusion for me
because in the beginning when we met
Diane it was a big surprise and we
thought that you know she was a little
bit different than a lot of us thought
she would have been then we found out
for sure in this episode that she was a
Tulpa so you know my original thought
was hey is she like evil COO you know
evil Coop's a doppelganger from what we
know I don't know if those two things
are the same I mean by definition
they're not exactly but obviously agent
Cooper's doppelganger is evil coop and
he has his own characteristics that make
him different his intention is different
than our beloved Dale Cooper who came
back in this last episode so I was
thinking that you know Diane might be a
completely different person while it
might still look like Laura Dern she may
have a personality that we expect and
this Tulpa version that we met with this
strange wig and all of that stuff may
actually just be like the evil coupe
version of Diane I don't really know for
sure though because it's not clear if
Tulpas and doppelgangers operate in the
same way so I'll just leave that
question for you guys well we're talking
about topos we might as well get into
this little bit of hair that Cooper gave
to Mike now a lot of people have thrown
the idea out there that the reason that
he did this was because he wants to make
a replacement for dougie Jones a copy of
himself that he can send to go live with
Janie E in sunny Jim on the surface that
seems possible there's also been an
equal amount of people that have said
that they really hope that's not the
case because they want to see the
original Dale Cooper go and live with
those two what we saw was the
asked Mike if he had the seed the seed
that came out of dougie Jones whenever
he was brought back into the red room
Mike shows it to him and then he pulls
out some hair and he gives it to him and
says he needs another one so it wouldn't
make you think that he wants another
copy would that copy be the same as him
or would it be like dougie Jones we
don't really have any clue about how
that works from what we saw dougie was
different than both evil coupe and agent
Cooper he had shared characteristics
like he was played by Kyle MacLachlan
but pretty much everything else was
different and unique so that's another
one you guys tell me what you think I
mean it's also not 100% sure that that's
what he was doing he did tell sunny Jim
and Janie he would come back and that's
where the idea comes from but it could
be something else altogether we can't
really just get stuck in that until we
know more about it the thing that's been
bothering me since I started making this
video well one of the things there's a
lot of that I don't really understand
here that I hope becomes clear in the
next episode
but when Richard and evil Cooper talking
evil coop tells them he has three sets
of coordinates two of which are the same
of course we see that Richard gets
trapped he falls into the trap whenever
he goes up to the court the coordinates
that we assume were the fake ones so I
started thinking about that and we know
that Phillip Jeffries gave him
coordinates and we know that ray gave
him coordinates but we never really
actually saw Dianne give him coordinates
until after she got the emoticon all
message after Richard dies now I checked
her coordinates because we could see
them she puts them all in there those
are the same ones that are on Ruth
Davenport's arm so that should be the
correct coordinates to Twin Peaks
because we saw her punch that into the
GPS but we never actually saw her send
him coordinates unless I'm forgetting
because it's getting to the point where
there's a lot of stuff to remember but
obviously Ray's coordinates would likely
be wrong because he was working for
Phillip Jeffries and they would match
the ones Phil Jeffries gave him so
that's two sets of bad coordinates but
where would he have gotten the third is
a mystery to me so anyways that's that
let's just move on because there's a big
rabbit hole
I keep thinking about it the next thing
was that you probably saw this but when
agent Cooper's leaving the hospital
first he has Bushnell call the mitchum
brothers but then he gives him a note
and I think this is really weird he
tells him if Gordon Cole shows up give
him this note and I don't understand why
he would do that like he knows Bushnell
has a phone and can use it I know coops
been asleep for 25 years and he's not
really you know he didn't use cell
phones back then and everything else but
like why would he give him a piece of
paper instead of contacting the FBI
directly more than that he's around
people like his wife and then he's with
the Mitchum's like he could definitely
get in touch with Gordon if he wants to
so I don't know I don't know what it
means at all but it seems kind of weird
to me so I thought I'd bring it up the
next thing you might have missed was
that the doctor who was taking care of
agent Cooper in the hospital is a
familiar face that we've seen before
in the credits she's just credited as
the female doctor and she was played by
the actress
valina Logan you might remember her
because in the original run she was the
desk clerk at the Great Northern and you
see these two side-by-side pictures and
you can see that it is definitely the
same actress does it mean anything
probably not you know she was in other
David Lynch projects so you know what I
mean he's someone that he knows and they
snuck her in there for a cameo the next
thing you might have missed was that the
sound that Bushnell heard
whenever Mike was coming and you know he
kind of got distracted from the room so
that Mike could talk to agent Cooper was
the same sound that you can hear in the
Great Northern and that James heard down
in the basement of the Great Northern
now people have called this a Tibetan
singing bowl sound I've never listened
to it cleaned up or anything like that
it just always sounds like a low hum but
from what I could tell and what I've
seen other people say it is actually the
same sound so that may give us a little
bit more to think about in relation to
the Great Northern what exactly I don't
know what to tell you but what it
reminds me of is the
fact that James walked right up to that
door was standing there and then we
never saw anything else about whether he
opened it or not so that is still out
there hanging the next thing you might
have missed was the guy who got into the
shootout with Chantel and Hutch was
credited as polish account in the
credits I had some people say that they
thought there was more to him and I
really don't think so I think it's kind
of just a plot device they needed they
needed something out of the blue to take
care of these two so that they wouldn't
be a problem for agent Cooper once he
woke up but either way he is called the
Polish accountant and I saw in Alexandra
Bond Eckstein's article she wrote that
this is not the first accountant we've
seen and basically what's up with the
accountants you know I mean we saw the
the farm after evil coupe wins the
armwrestling match and he's sitting
there getting ready to kill ray we see
this sort of mica SH guy there who's
known as the farm accountant he asked
him if he wants any money and then in
the very beginning of the series our
first shot at the Twin Peaks Sheriff's
Department there was a guy who was
credited as an accountant insurance
agent who came looking for sheriff
Truman and we got that that's when we
found out that Harry was actually sick
so is it just a weird thing that they
like to use or what I don't know but
it's kind of funny and when you think
about it because the guy could have been
anything I mean he was in a dispute over
an inch of his driveway being blocked he
could have been named anything for sure
but they chose to call him the Polish
accountant so it's interesting even
though there's nothing that I can really
tell you better about it and the last
major thing that you might have missed I
know I did I saw this a couple places
afterwards after Audrey does her dance
and we see her wake up or should we see
her look in the mirror and the white
room it goes back to the Roadhouse where
the music is continuing to play all the
way through the credits only this time
it's actually playing backwards so the
song doesn't change we see a shot of the
band as they're playing but it's
actually played in Reverse when I
watched it I thought something seemed
off
but then I just thought it was maybe a
really cool shot because of the way that
it was set up or something like that but
it turns out that it's been confirmed
that it is backwards and what that means
is another mystery so yeah this was a
awesome episode part 16 I said at the
beginning of my top moments video that
not much happened what I meant was that
there aren't that many stories going
wild like you know and if we think about
like some of the other big ones like
pisode 7 or episode 11 some of these
ones that were big rollercoaster rides
there were so many different stories
that were getting bouncing back and
forth from now we're really down to the
main movement into the final chapter the
Toba thing is interesting I do hope we
find out more about that something
people I brought up that I've seen
posted around in different places is
that Diane says that she's in the
Sheriff's Department and this makes
people think that she is Naito
which is kind of like well the other
thing everybody thinks is NIDA has maybe
Judy both of these are I can see where
people are coming from but I don't think
we have enough information to really go
from that I mean we know that according
to the story
Diane was taken to what sounds like the
convenience store and obviously a
duplicate was made at some point how
that equates to the original being a
Japanese woman with no eyes I don't
really know I'm not saying it is
impossible I'm just saying that the only
real connection there is that Nadeau
came from the other side and is now at
the sheriff's station on the other hand
the fact that people think she's Judy
kind of goes back to the idea that Judy
is Josie's half-sister that's not a
really strong case for that either I
think we will figure out what's going on
with NATO for sure
I was thinking earlier do you really
want this to be like two episodes of
twin peaks' the return or are you hoping
for like a two-hour movie set up kind of
like fire walk with me I think it's
always been the intention to show these
two episodes back-to-back as the finale
so I'm hoping it's more of a two-hour
long story but we'll see
what happens I did put out a video
yesterday just posing the question of
what your three biggest questions you'd
like to see answered in the finale are
you should check that out and put your
comments there I'm planning a preview of
sorts video on Saturday so I'll be
looking over all those and talking about
what I want to see done and what I want
to get answers to it's really hard to do
and I can't believe it's actually here
the finale is actually here I've never
been so excited and so disappointed at
the same time like I can't wait to see
what happens but I'm gonna miss this
show and it's gone for sure so give the
video a like if you enjoyed it please
subscribe to my channel if you haven't
already turn on notifications so you'll
get my new videos as soon as they come
out I hope you guys will stick around
with me after Twin Peaks wraps up but I
will be doing quite a few things between
now and then make sure you follow me on
Twitter so you can interact with me
there and on my other social media
accounts thanks for watching guys I'll
talk to you soon